every day's a battle for the Rangers a
battle to save the world's largest ape
but their challenges are huge the area
they're protecting is around 6000 square
kilometres our drone just shows you a
tiny portion of it it's more than twice
the size of Luxembourg most of its
unreachable by vehicle so the hard graft
is Donald foot hacking their way through
dense jungle but it comes with risks a
number of armed gangs hideout here and
dozens of the Rangers have been
kidnapped for ransom some have been
killed and it's all for this creature
the growls gorilla there are only a few
thousand of this gorilla subspecies left
in the world the troubled country of dr
congo is the only place they're found
but in the land where most are hungry
these gorillas are being poached and
killed for meat or hunted by rebel
groups trying to clear the way for gold
mining to fund their warfare the Rangers
know the gorillas well and this is Chi
Manuka the patriarch we're asked to wear
masks to avoid passing on germs to this
critically endangered species this is
the King Kong it's horrible to think
could be extinct in as little as five
years and it's all because of humans
humans are to blame
because the gorillas tend to live in
family groups they're easy prey for
poachers this is to Monica's youngest a
baby of only four years old curious
about our camera and sulky when he's
warned off by the Rangers some of the
Rangers of former poachers themselves
like Oscar now appalled at his previous
behavior yellow are cutting in kanawa
quarry before I killed lots of gorillas
he says it was my life because I needed
to make money but now with this job I
can protect them and get money they now
believe by ensuring the growers survival
they help their own survival too they
would suffer without the gorillas he
says there'd be no jobs no money no
future but it's taking time convincing
the communities here they're growing
coffee a relatively new plantation and
they won't get paid until it starts
yielding the workers are mostly former
poachers one shows us how we used to
kill the gorillas the gorillas body
would feed a hundred and fifty villagers
not killing gorillas means they're all
hungry
they live in pitiful conditions even
with his new job and fresh hope Boogaloo
says there's never enough food to feed
his family of eight we shall order I
can't decide who eats and who doesn't so
I give a small bit to all of them so
while the surrounding communities
struggled for survival the gorilla does
too and the message that there are
alternatives to slaughtering this animal
is taking time
time the growls gorilla is running out
of Alex Crawford Sky News in the
Democratic Republic of Congo